avant que la vidéo commence j'aimerais
annoncer la venue d'un partenariat avec
la chaîne il s'agit d' in stone gaming
est un très grand merci à eux pour leur
confiance pour les intéressés vous
retrouverez le lien d'un concours dans
la description c'est un concours qui
sera renouvelée chaque mois pour
participer il vous suffit d'entrer le
nom du jeu que vous souhaitez que ce
soit sur pc aux consoles et voilà
maintenant la chance doit opérer pour
vous sachez en tout cas que ce
partenariat est un énorme soutien pour
moi et le développement de la chaîne
alors n'hésitez pas à participer je sais
qu'il y a des grandes dames de gamer en
vous et puis cela ne vous engage en rien
vous avez plutôt l'opportunité de gagner
un jeu à la clé quoi bref merci enstone
gaming
bienvenue dans ce nouveau trois théories
qui est une vidéo que j'attendais
expressément de vous faire je ne voulait
jamais caché pour moi docteur strange
est le héros qui me hype le plus
clairement un c'est mon héros préférés
du mc hull
on a déjà beaucoup parler de lui et
c'est l'occasion là de mettre à jour les
nouvelles infos etc et donc de vous
proposer de nouvelles théories
accompagné de mon cher ami heroes seif
qui d'ailleurs lui aussi vous propose
une vidéo de son côté 1 que je conseille
d'aller voir
nous allons tenter de résoudre et
soulevé certains mystères voilà du
second opus de doctor strange soit
docteur strange de multivers of madness
et voilà j'espère que ça vous plaira
tout simplement et évidemment je vous le
rappelle mais vous êtes très nombreux à
regarder les vidéos sans être abonné à
la chaîne c'est le moment de le faire
n'hésitez pas à rejoindre la communauté
bref il est grand temps maintenant
d'amener les théories aller
let's go
[Musique]
wang da et strange se ressemblent
terriblement et sont à la fois très
éloignées ils sont tous les deux les
sorciers des avengers l'un maîtrisant
les arts mystiques le savoir théorique
la sagesse reconnu d'ailleurs par tous
comme le sorcier suprême un titre très
important alors que de l'autre côté nous
sommes plus sur un pouvoir brut
une puissance qui dépasse tout
entendement voire sauvage et indomptable
et surtout qui n'a demandé aucune
pratique
nous sommes sur une opposition est à la
fois une complémentarité impuissant
équilibre jailli de ses deux personnages
méaugon nous la chance de voir cet
équilibre l'un des facteurs qui nous
permettra de le voir et pour moi le dark
old livre de sorcellerie détenus au
premier abord par agatha puis récupéré
par rwanda ce livre symbolise surtout
des millions d'années de savoir magique
d'histoire et autres légendes un livre
donc très dangereux mais qui cache de
très nombreuses réponses à nouveau une
sorte d' équilibre wendat en est la
propriétaire et l'exploitent pour
accroître ses pouvoirs et sa maîtrise
mais dans le symbole nous savons que
wendat est la scarlet witch débordant de
magie du chaos
un pouvoir qui la dépasse et qui peut la
conduire à la folie wendat peut devenir
très dangereuse
mais dans cet équilibre est entre de
bonnes mains le dark auld pourrait
servir également à dr strange dans un
but plus en outre tout l'aspect
métaphorique que je vous propose depuis
le début doctor strange est un être de
savoir ce dernier maîtrise la
connaissance et tout l'aspect théorique
que doit connaître un sorcier suprême
sauf à l'exception
d'un seul livre la fameuse théorie du
livre manquants
dans l'origine story du docteur un
livre- mans que dans la réserve de k
mart âge un livre qui pourrait être le
dark rôle d' étant à la recherche de la
pierre du temps sont artefacts ultime
qu'il doit préserver peu importe les
circonstances
le dark auld pourrait guider docteur
strange sur sa quête de retrouver la
pierre du temps et d'en apprendre
beaucoup sur elle plus qu'il ne le sais
déjà ce que je veux dire par là et pour
appuyer l'idée les pierre d'infini sont
loin d'être connue de tous et ont été
éparpillés à travers l'univers pendant
des milliers d'années
pourtant une jeune sorcière de la
planète terre a conscience de
l'existence de ces dernières c'est
agatha la seule raison évidente et la
mention de ces dernières dans le dark
old dark auld qui détaillent le rôle de
la scarlet witch scarlet witch qui est
née grâce à la pierre de l'esprit étant
le livre ultime des sorciers et
sorcières recueillant à savoir de
plusieurs millénaires ce dernier
cacheraient des informations sur les
pierres d'infinité et notamment la
pierre du temps dans une cohérence
scénaristique le dark roll de prendre
est en quelque sorte le rôle de pierre
par rapport à une finition wargame en
devenant l'artefact ultime à conquérir
par tous je connais d'ailleurs un
sorcier déchu qui souhaiteraient
l'exploiter dans tous les cas ce dernier
symboliserait le conflit entre luanda et
doctor strange avant de voir
possiblement une alliance et une
complémentarité
face à un ennemi commun
[Musique]
le caractère ultime du docteur nous est
montré depuis son premier film en 2016
ce dernier a réussi à piéger dormammu il
est censé devenir le meilleur des
sorciers suprême il a tenu face à thanos
équipé des cinq pierres bref docteur
strange rime avec master glace néanmoins
il existe quelque chose que strange ne
maîtrise pas encore quelque chose qui
symbolise sa fonction et son devoir de
sorcier suprême et qui n'a jamais été
encore montré à l'écran les être extra
dimensionnelle c'est peut être simple et
idiot de penser ceci mais malgré la
maîtrise de stephen strange nous sommes
encore à l'aube de son plein potentiel
dans le mc u6 strange savait
véritablement manipuler les voyages
entre les réalités les dimensions nous
l'aurions déjà vu à l'écran
nous aurions déjà des entités externe à
l'univers dans le mc eu et c'est quelque
chose qui peut rejoindre la théorie
précédente
et si le savoir manquants a strange
concernant le multivers se trouvait dans
le livre manquant le possible d' art
gold le seul manuscrit que strange n'a
pas pu étudier
al'inverse de luanda qui d'ailleurs
entend la voix lointaine de ses enfants
dans sa scène post générique dans l'idée
et cela peut se produire dans spider man
3 ou dans doctor strange 2 une entité
externe à la dimension principal voire
de l'univers dans lequel nous sommes
pourrait faire son apparition et
atterrir sur la terre que nous
connaissons dr strange ayant pour devoir
de protéger le mans des êtres externe à
notre dimension serait le premier alerté
lui permettant de découvrir et de
développer cet aspect encore inconnue
pour lui le premier pas dans le
multivers néanmoins plusieurs cas de
figure sont possibles
luanda et la cliente idéale pour être
celle qui va ouvrir une page
esch une porte ouverte à d'autres
réalités dimension univers de par
l'appel de ces enfants normalement
disparu en pratiquant de savoir contenu
dans le dark old wendat a pu réveiller
ou ouvrir quelque chose cependant il
existe deux autres cas intéressant à
souligner america chavez est une héroïne
confirmé pour doctor strange 2 et nous
verrons normalement ses premiers pas à
l'écran dans ce film et sa particularité
que america chavez n'est pas originaire
de notre univers puisque c'est suite à
la perte de ces mères et de son lieu de
vie qu'elle s'est retrouvée sur terre à
l'âge de 6 ans pour une réadaptation du
nc l'ouverture d'une brèche accédant à
d'autres réalités ou univers pourrait
être provoquée par la fuite d'america
chavez dans notre univers réveillant
donc docteur strange sur son devoir et
amenant la problématique de la venue
d'un être non malveillants mais qui ne
devait pas être là à la base mais le cas
spider man 3 n'est pas à écarter non
plus malgré toutes les rumeurs et
faisant partie de la trilogie wendat
vision spider man 3 dr strange 2 le
troisième film de l'homme araignée
pourrait symboliser l'introduction pour
strange concernant un possible multivers
permettant pour le deuxième film de
rentrer directement dans le concret sans
avoir à installer tous à idées déjà
caressé par mystérieux qui dans sa
tromperie mentionnant le multivers
démontre l'intérêt de marvel studios
d'introduire tout ce concept par le
biais de spider man concept propulsé par
l'existence de spider man in tous styles
anvers est également qui démontre par le
biais de mystérieux la conscience qu'un
tel concept existe dans l'univers
l'identité de peter est en révélé de
manière injuste speedy pourrait partir
en cavale
accompagné de michelle et ned pour
trouver justice afin de justifier la
présence de stephen strange spy dit au
crès à la porte du docteur pour l'aider
à résoudre cette crise pensant notamment
à la pierre du temps où un spider man
externe
qui pourrait échanger les identités tout
en permettant de sauver peter et lui
garder son anonymat
bref je pars un peu loin mais au final
qui sera l'élément perturbateur qui
réveillera strange sur son rôle et il
lui permettra de découvrir le savoir qui
lui manquait
[Musique]
pour conclure il est temps de parler de
vilains de méchants d'antagonistes
néanmoins nous avions déjà parlé de tout
ça dans la dernière vidéo dédiée à oujda
vision c'est pourquoi j'aimerais
aujourd'hui me concentrer sur le
personnage de mort dos 1-1 antagonistes
dont on ne parle pas assez et qui
pourtant est hyper important pour le
développement de strange déjà plusieurs
choses sont à souligner bordeaux est un
adepte des arts mystiques
suite à la découverte que l'ancien se
servait de la dimension noir pour
assurer son immortalité et que strange a
utilisé la pierre du temps donc
enfreindre les règles de l'univers pour
contrer dormammu et bien ce dernier a
vrillé jugeant qu'il existe trop de
sorcier et donc qu'il doit les supprimer
en gros du coup mort d'eau est
aujourd'hui un antagoniste de strange et
c'est obligé qu'on le revoit certains
lots suspects même d'être l'ennemi
ultime de dr strange dans son second
film cependant même si l'idée paraît
alléchante quelque chose cloche par
rapport à ça depuis le début du
développement du film et de l'arc
multivers il y a tout un mystère
existant autour du méchant à la base
nightmare prévu par scott derrickson
puis à la reprise de sam raimi le dieu
du chaos octobre est clairement
envisageable ou encore méphisto par
exemple sauf que concernant mort de
l'acteur est donc son personnage est
confirmée pour le film et ce depuis bien
deux ans c'est tout bête mais cela
casserait un mystère énorme
on ne connaît pas le véritable
antagonistes ni l'acteur pour le moment
alors tout serait gâcher en quelque
sorte si c'était mort 2 mais ce dernier
sera là et c'est un fait
dans ma vision personnelle et par
rapport au caractère de mort d'eau dans
les comics ce dernier n'hésite pas à
user de magie interdite en quelque sorte
contraire à ses convictions
par exemple la dimension noir pacte et
avec dormammu et caetera et c'est dans
une adaptation pour le mc eu mort d'eau
dans sa haine deviendrait clairement ce
qu'ils combattaient au début alors dans
l'idée nous pourrions avoir un bordeaux
qu'il soutiendrait luanda pour
confronter strange est le défaire ce
dernier n'hésite pas à faire les coûts
les plus bas à être bien sournois avoir
triché comme dans un célèbre combat des
comics donc c'est une possibilité mais
il se pourrait aussi que bordeaux soit
intéressé par le dark auld pour
justement libérer une grande menace afin
d'éradiquer les sorciers dont strange je
pense bien évidemment achten qui par
rapport à son histoire pourrait être
libéré de sa dimension grâce aux livres
néanmoins dans une logique scénaristique
bordeaux ne peut pas apparaître comme ça
par hasard
malgré son absence dans infinity ward et
endgame ce dernier a dû certainement se
développer et absorber les pouvoirs
d'autres sorciers pour s'élever afin
d'arriver au rang de strange qui est le
sorcier suprême donc si nous retrouvons
bordeaux dans le second film cela veut
dire que ce dernier est prêt et traque
strange et où honda à travers la terre
peut être que grâce à l'ex apparu dans
wendat vision il aurait trouvé la trace
du passage de wendat et possiblement la
présence d'agata auxquels ils pourraient
s'allier avant de la trahir tout est
possible dans tous les cas ce second
opus n'est pas le moment où mort d'eau
va briller d'après moi stephen strange a
encore beaucoup de chemin à parcourir et
d'autres films solo à nous proposer
sachant que cléa pourrait également
apparaître à l'écran il y encore
beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à proposer
merci à tous d'avoir regardé ce trois
théories et j'espère sincèrement que ça
vous a plu et puis bah merci airoh de
m'avoir accompagné durant cette vidéo en
tout cas marvel c'est que doctor strange
de et possiblement leur film le plus
attendu
pour le moment il sort dans moins d'un
an normalement mais il y a encore
beaucoup d'informations cacher on sait
très peu de choses sur le film ans ils
le font exprès évidemment ça promet en
tout cas d'être grandiose évidemment je
vous ai proposé ma vision totalement
personnelle sur le sujet ce que
j'attends du film ce que je pense qu'il
va y avoir dans le film et c'est à vous
maintenant de me proposer dans les
commentaires
vos idées ce que vous vous en pensez et
cetera qu'est ce que vous attendez de
voir dans ce docteur strange et enfin
bas j'aimerais vous annoncer aussi que
je pense qu'il est temps pour moi de
d'approché de nouveaux horizons et de
tenter de nouvelles choses
youtube est depuis des années ma seule
et unique présence sur internet dans la
création de contenu etc
je compte pas twitter et instagram même
si évidemment je vous encourage à me
suivre là bas et du coup j'aimerais en
fait ne plus avoir tous les oeufs dans
le même panier quoi on va dire et tenter
pourquoi pas laventure aussi sur twitch
avant de vous proposer des théories tout
ça les live c'est quelque chose que je
faisais énormément 1 j'en faisais sur
des jeux vidéo est tout et j'avoue que
c'est une expérience qui manque un peu
et que j'aimerais bien faire en
parallèle aussi de youtube
évidemment cela ne remet pas du tout en
cause la chaîne ma productivité etc
ça reste toujours pareil youtube ça
change pas ça reste mon truc principal
n'y aura pas de réduction de vidéos ou
autres où je n'abandonne pas la chaîne
ou je ne sais pas quoi bref qui a pas
d'idée à ce faire mais voilà j'aimerais
tenter enfin plutôt re tenter cette
expérience et puis voilà un peu changer
d'air pendant ce nouveau confinement
quoi je pense que vous comprenez l'idée
donc si ça vous intéresse ou si ça vous
intrigue
écoutez je vous laisse aller voir
le lien de la chaîne switch dans la
description peut-être même qu'au moment
où vous regardez cette vidéo bas serait
en live enfin voilà quoi écouter
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
a laissé un petit pouce bleus et puis
voilà quoi que le lionheart soit avec
vous bon courage à tous pour ce nouveau
confinement et cetera allez ciao tout le
monde
[Musique]